the last royal to come to the ruins at
cahill pech was the queen in her
platinum jubilee year her grandson and
granddaughter-in-law were the ones
delivering her warm wishes
long live the queen que viva la reina
william used the moment to recall his
grandmother's words of praise for belize
in 1994 to then condemn the horrors
taking place in ukraine
she said
i am proud to associate myself with your
determination
that social justice and personal freedom
should flourish under the rule of law
it is always dangerous however
to be complacent and to assume that
democratic values will look after
themselves
vigilance in protecting them
is needed
sadly
elsewhere in the world
that vigilance is being tested today in
ukraine
belize has joined many others in
condemning the invasion
and standing out for the principles of
international law
peace and security
today we think of those struggling in
ukraine
and we stand with them in solidarity
it was a reminder these tours aren't all
about sightseeing after mourning among
the mayan ruins at caracal
the couple standing on the sky palace
still the largest man-made structure in
belize was the picture until they were
joined by some of us
these pictures are priceless for the
people of belize a tour brings immense
global attention and a stage the royal
couple know they can also personally use
to deliver the messages that matters so
much to them
rhiannon mills sky news in belize